[MUSIC PLAYING]
BROOKE HEINICHEN:
So give a round
of applause for Matt
Ingebretson, Jake Weisman,
and Pat Bishop.
MATT INGEBRETSON: Hey, hey.
[APPLAUSE]
BROOKE HEINICHEN: Guys.
Have a seat.
MATT INGEBRETSON: Hello.
Thanks for having us.
BROOKE HEINICHEN:
Welcome to Google.
So we just got the
opportunity to check out
episode 4 of "Corporate."
What did you guys think?
[APPLAUSE]
MATT INGEBRETSON: Thanks.
BROOKE HEINICHEN: So why
don't we kick it off?
You guys can just talk
a little about the show
and your inspirations and
how you sort of came up
with the very unique concept
for an office-based show.
MATT INGEBRETSON: Yeah,
well, first of all, I'm
excited to be at Google.
I owe you guys my life.
If you guys went away, things
would crumble so quickly.
I'm desperate for you.
Thank you so much.
JAKE WEISMAN: Well, I mean--
I don't share those sentiments.
I'm just kidding.
I do.
Thanks for everything.
I think, first of
all, obviously,
it's a darker look at
office life, which we--
but it's frustrating
when people call it dark,
because it's also, just
I think, more honest.
You guys have a lot of smiles on
your face, which we don't often
see at offices.
MATT INGEBRETSON: You guys'
snack room is incredible,
by the way.
I stole so much
food from you guys.
Thank you for that as well.
JAKE WEISMAN: Yeah.
I think that we were
trying to make--
trying to do a few things.
One of the first
things we wanted to do
was create a show about
working that is a little more
honest than other shows.
And when "The Office" came out,
which I think is a great show--
the American version-- it
was considered like dark,
but it's so goofy and so silly
and has a really goofy boss.
And it's actually just about how
people get along at a company.
And the real wonderful part
of work is your coworkers.
And I think our point
is everyone's sad.
There's no God.
And you're going to die
screaming into the void.
So you think about that when
you're at work, wondering
where your life went wrong.
That was one of the first
things we wanted to do,
was portray office life, how
most people feel about it.
MATT INGEBRETSON: Yeah,
some of the inspirations
came from day jobs I had
working at large corporations
that I dreaded going
into work every day.
I typically left on Friday
not excited about the weekend,
but just wanting to
kill myself that I
was going to have to come
back there on Monday again.
And again, maybe this
doesn't apply to you guys,
because you work at
a wonderful company,
who, again, I owe my life to.
Thank you again.
JAKE WEISMAN: But
overall, you're not happy.
MATT INGEBRETSON:
Yeah, we know--
we see the sadness in your eyes.
JAKE WEISMAN: You live in
SF and you're open-minded,
but you're sad.
MATT INGEBRETSON:
You work at Google,
and this was like a dream
for you, but you come here
and the snacks don't matter
to you anymore, which
is why I stole them from you.
I know you don't
actually care about them.
But yeah, so that's the
inspiration for the show.
And we're fans of
like-- we also, I
think, were frustrated
with a lot of TV comedies.
I should be talking
to you, I guess.
BROOKE HEINICHEN:
Nah, talk to them.
JAKE WEISMAN: Oh, yeah,
what are we supposed to do?
MATT INGEBRETSON: Whatever.
It doesn't matter.
JAKE WEISMAN: The
camera's over other.
BROOKE HEINICHEN:
Nothing matters.
MATT INGEBRETSON:
But yeah, I think
frustrated with a
lot of TV comedies
just feeling a little lazy
in terms of how they shot it
and the filmmaking of it and
not taking advantage of the fact
that they're using cameras that
can do anything they fucking
want.
And-- I can-- it doesn't matter.
JAKE WEISMAN: Yeah,
you can curse.
PAT BISHOP: But not at Google.
MATT INGEBRETSON:
Yeah, not at Google.
The censors of Google.
And so we wanted to
make a little more
of an ambitious show
for Comedy Central that
felt a little darker in tone
than what they would typically
do.
BROOKE HEINICHEN: Can you
talk a lot about like--
are there any parts of the
storyline that are specifically
inspired by specific
instances that you've
had in your work life?
MATT INGEBRETSON:
Yeah, a lot of them.
The episode that
aired last night--
was that last night?
JAKE WEISMAN: No.
MATT INGEBRETSON: What is today?
Saturday?
PAT BISHOP: Friday.
MATT INGEBRETSON: Friday.
Wednesday.
Our show is on at Wednesdays
at 10:00 PM on Comedy Central.
In an episode about my
character taking naps in his car
in the parking garage at
work, which is something
that I actually did and got
caught doing by my boss,
and it was a humiliating
experience for me.
And Jake's storyline
is about him
getting spinal fusion surgery,
which you actually did.
JAKE WEISMAN: Yeah,
well, and also people
that I dated and friends
of mine would check in
on me when I was recovering.
And I thought they
cared about me,
but they just wanted
my pain pills.
MATT INGEBRETSON: It was an
incredible learning experience.
JAKE WEISMAN: Opioid
addiction in America is real.
MATT INGEBRETSON: Yeah.
JAKE WEISMAN: But yeah, I
think what we tried to do--
the truth is, also, that
when writing the show,
beyond the pilot, we
did interview people
from your company and from
Amazon and other corporations,
and were like, off the
record, how bad is it?
And we tried to-- we had
postulated theories about what
it's like to work
in corporations,
and we had some specifics
given, but mostly,
it was just confirmed that
there's-- even in a wonderful
environment like Google, there's
just all this bureaucracy,
this necessary insanity
that can't be avoided.
We tried to include as
much as that as possible.
BROOKE HEINICHEN: Oh, good.
Good to know Google is
not secluded from that.
So I mean, I feel like if
I had watched the show--
I used to work in a much
more corporate environment
in my prior job--
I feel like if I
watched this, I'd
be very depressed, because
it doesn't seem like there's
much of a way out or much hope.
Is there any hope for people
that work at Hampton Deville?
MATT INGEBRETSON:
I don't think so.
Or I mean, like
maybe quit your job.
We had-- I told this story once,
but we had a friend of ours
who worked at a very
corporate job watch
the pilot when that
was all we had made.
We had just made the
pilot, and she watched it.
And then shortly after
went and did ayahuasca,
which everyone at Google
knows what ayahuasca is--
I assume-- did ayahuasca.
And while she was hallucinating,
had hallucinations of our show.
And it like was a life-changing
experience for her.
When she got back,
she quit her job.
So I think that's the
goal of this show.
I don't-- is to get people to do
intense hallucinogens and then
abandon their life.
I think that-- I
don't know if there's
a ton of hope in
this show, but I
think that there is catharsis in
it, in that like we understand
what you're going through.
There's a darkness to it that
hopefully you can relate to.
I just don't think there's
a lot of hope in life.
I think you can like--
you can be good to one
another, and that's
about the best you can do.
But in terms of like
working in this environment,
it is-- it typically
feels a little hopeless.
PAT BISHOP: I
mean, I feel like--
well, we work for Viacom.
And we managed to like make a
show that makes fun of Viacom,
among other things that we--
I feel like we sort of
succeeded by turning
the system against itself.
BROOKE HEINICHEN: Yeah,
I just watched that.
There was a quote in that
episode that was like,
"All great artists
sell out," and you guys
work for Comedy Central and
are doing a talk at Google.
So does that make you guys?
PAT BISHOP: Yeah, I think.
MATT INGEBRETSON: We're
absolutely sellouts.
Absolutely.
JAKE WEISMAN: There's
a movie called
"SLC Punk!" that has a
great line where he's
like, "I'm not selling out.
I'm buying in."
And I feel like in a world and
especially a country structured
for corporations to
win every single time,
the best you can do is
buy in and try to be
nice to the people around you.
What are you supposed to do?
Even if you go
live off the grid,
you're doing that in
reaction to a corporation.
So all you can do is try to find
as good a situation as possible
that a corporation
is letting you do.
MATT INGEBRETSON: I
do think if you're
in the darkest
moments of your life,
this show might
be-- you might want
to watch like
"Lord of the Rings"
or something that's escapist,
like takes you out of it.
JAKE WEISMAN: Yeah,
"Lord of the Rings,"
that movie that
always takes you out.
MATT INGEBRETSON: I don't
know why that came to mind.
I haven't seen "Lord of the
Rings" in like 15 years,
but that's top of mind for
me today for some reason.
BROOKE HEINICHEN: It seems like
your two main characters, Matt
and Jake, are pretty unaffected
by the corporate brainwash.
Why are they the only two?
Or do you think that
other characters
will come out as cynical?
JAKE WEISMAN: I think
unaffected maybe
like how our
characters seem, but I
think both of the
characters' lives
are completely in
reaction to corporations.
Like my character-- I don't know
if you guys have seen the pilot
or not-- but my character
used to be in a punk band
and really failed at that.
And he wanted to be an artist.
He also was a street artist.
He tried to express himself
artistically, failed at that,
and realized that, oh, the
world is a capitalist nightmare,
so I have to buy in.
So I'm still structuring my
life around a corporation.
I've just-- it's just basically
because also I'm depressed.
And so it's like, OK,
well, this is what life is.
I'll just live it out.
MATT INGEBRETSON: I
think, too, that we
tried to explore,
build into the show
the idea that it's
no character's
like fault necessarily
that they're behaving badly
to some extent.
It's like the fact
that they're a part
of this larger corporation
that's doing very bad things.
And so like the bosses
that we have in the show
are both essentially
psychopaths who
behave like maniacs towards us.
But I think that they're just
further along down this path
than we are, and have been
corrupted a little more deeply
than we have.
BROOKE HEINICHEN:
They were once you?
JAKE WEISMAN: Yeah, in the
episode, in the season finale,
you'll see--
I'm not going to say what
happens-- but you'll see them
in our position, like
a flashback to them
in our position.
So they used to be
excited like us,
but they've been beaten
down, and now they're rich.
MATT INGEBRETSON: Yeah.
BROOKE HEINICHEN: So it
doesn't matter anymore.
Well, Pat, I want to give you
a chance to talk a little bit.
Pat is the writer and director
and editor of the show.
So can you talk
about the choices
you made as a director that
differentiates this idea,
either from other office
comedies or your past work?
There's some more
obvious things.
There's the darkness,
like the actual darkness
of the shots, the music.
So can you just talk about
some of your choices there?
PAT BISHOP: Yeah, I think an
idea we had from the start
was that we wanted to
make it more cinematic.
And I think most companies
are kind of brightly lit
and have bright colors, because
it is supposed to be fun
and you're supposed
to want to hang out
with this group of friends.
But for this show, the
story we wanted to tell,
we needed it to
be darker and make
it feel a little
oppressive to be there.
So yeah, we borrowed from
people like David Fincher
or like kind of just more
dramatic kind of sources
and mixed that in with
the comedy and stuff.
And we also got like
dramatic actors,
like Lance Reddick from "The
Wire," and Anne Dudek who
plays Kate on the show has
been in a bunch of stuff.
And we tried to just kind of
take it more seriously in a way
and let the kind
of absurd things
that were happening play
in contrast to that.
MATT INGEBRETSON: Yeah, I think
a lot of our favorite movies
and stuff are not things
that are pure comedies.
They exist in a
sort of like drama
but that dips into comedy world.
So we wanted to be a little
more in that vein than something
that takes everything
extremely likely, I think.
BROOKE HEINICHEN: I'm curious.
What would those
be, those dramas?
JAKE WEISMAN: Well,
we love like the Coen
brothers and Paul Thomas
Anderson and stuff,
where's it's like--
"Boogie Nights" is a sprawling
drama, but really funny.
And the Coen brothers
movies look incredible.
And then so when the jokes come
out of these incredibly well
lit scenes-- and Pat has said
this before-- it's almost
like the joke is you set
up this beautiful painting,
and then said something stupid.
Like that's the joke itself.
It's the fact that
you did all this work
to say a dumb joke
about a penis.
You know what I mean?
And that's like,
that's the joke.
But also--
MATT INGEBRETSON: We like
people like Todd Solondz.
Does anybody know
who Todd Solondz is?
JAKE WEISMAN: He did "Welcome to
the Dollhouse" and "Happiness,"
but just really
like bleak humor.
But also-- and I've talked
about this a bunch--
but the movie "Airplane!"
is a really incredible comedy.
It's very silly, but what
people don't remember
is it's a drama that's just
taken in a very silly way.
Like Leslie Nielsen
was a dramatic actor,
and they picked him to
do extremely dumb jokes.
But if you watch
"Airplane!", it's
an intense drama about something
happening in an airplane
and the dumbest
stuff is happening.
I think we're more in that vein.
We're getting Lance Reddick,
who could read the phone book
and you'd be engrossed, to
say incredibly dumb things.
And that, to us, is
just the best comedy.
And it's also just we're
trying to make a satire.
And so it has to look good.
Otherwise, you don't think
we're talking about anything.
BROOKE HEINICHEN:
It makes sense.
What's it like to work with
Lance or Aparna and the other--
MATT INGEBRETSON:
Lance is incredible.
He's very intimidating.
He's like-- he made me feel
ashamed of my acting abilities.
He's like a meticulously
prepared perfect actor.
And offscreen, he's
like the sweetest guy,
who is a great listener and
super politically minded.
He's like amazing, A-plus.
And Aparna is like a unicorn
genius, like brain-exploding,
wonderful person, who we
were lucky to work with,
because she just brings--
she adds like so many other
layers to the character
that we're not
necessarily even on.
JAKE WEISMAN: I think one
thing that we're good at is--
and this is an obvious thing
you're told a lot, I think,
in business, but
then when you do it,
you realize how important
it is-- you just pick
people better than you.
And you get the credit for it.
So we just like cast people
that are way smarter,
way funnier, way more talented.
And then, since we wrote
it, then everyone is like,
wow, you did it.
But they're the best people.
We just cast them.
We just cast well.
Everyone we cast was
like a friend or someone
we really admired.
And we wrote Baron
Vaughn into the show.
He wasn't in that episode,
but he's a genius.
We wrote for specific people,
and we cast it extremely well.
And that just does
so much of the work.
BROOKE HEINICHEN: I feel
like every episode has
like this very stark, if
not written out on a bumper
sticker, reminder that
we're all going to die,
in case you didn't know.
So why that message?
Especially why Comedy Central?
JAKE WEISMAN: Why
did we do this?
BROOKE HEINICHEN: Yeah.
Do you think people
are expecting
to turn Comedy Central and
be like, ah, I want to die.
MATT INGEBRETSON:
We did-- we have
gotten that question a little
bit of like, why did you
do this?
Or like, why did you make a show
with this type of messaging?
For me, it was I
found it extremely--
I have found it extremely
helpful in my life
to get that messaging
drilled into my head, which
is like, you're going
to die, but that's fine.
We're all going to die.
That's OK.
It's very comforting to me.
I'm sure it isn't for
everybody, but like--
JAKE WEISMAN: Who here is
thinking about dying right now?
MATT INGEBRETSON: Yeah.
JAKE WEISMAN: None of you?
I don't believe anyone of you.
I'm thinking about
dying right now.
On the plane here
just a few hours ago,
Matt and I were
having a conversation.
It's like, if the plane crashed
right now, it'd be fine.
MATT INGEBRETSON: Yeah.
BROOKE HEINICHEN: Because if you
die, then there's no more pain.
If you live, we get
to do cool stuff.
But if you die, it's over.
It's not that big a deal.
And I think the craziest
thing about life
is that you're going to die.
It's like-- it's the
best joke possible.
It's structured as a joke.
You do all this stuff.
Create a family.
Build a career.
Ah, man, get mad at people
who break up with you.
Do an amazing things.
Learn lessons.
And then it's over, and
it really doesn't matter.
So that's just, to me,
the essence of comedy.
There's a lot of like great
satirists, a lot of like--
French people who smoked
cigarettes and wrote
bleak things all
wrote about that.
And so I just don't-- the thing
is, so much comedy avoids that.
It's all escapism.
And pure just mirth.
And it's sometimes
funny, but it's not
based in the human truth,
where most of the people--
being around comedians,
you think they're silly,
but they're really
serious people.
And they're thinking about
this stuff all the time.
And we just-- that's
what we think is funny.
PAT BISHOP: Yeah,
I think there are
some comedies that start
with like a depressed parent
or something who is not happy
with their life and whatever.
And then the answer for them
is like, go to Vegas and party.
Have a crazy weekend.
But that's not an answer.
There is no great answer.
MATT INGEBRETSON: Yeah.
JAKE WEISMAN: It's just sort
of like, I think the problem--
one of the problems in life
is that we look at things--
we call certain things dark.
And that is because
we're-- that's incorrect.
Death is not dark.
It's just a fact of life.
You know what I mean?
Things that are dark
shouldn't be called dark.
They're just things that are.
But we call them dark,
because we're afraid of them.
So if you talk
about death and you
talk about whatever people
perceive as darkness,
you're deflating the balloon.
You can live a better
life in the meantime.
If you don't take
life so seriously,
you can have a
better time, I think.
BROOKE HEINICHEN: You should
be a motivational speaker.
JAKE WEISMAN: Listen to me.
MATT INGEBRETSON: Jake
as a motivational speaker
would be a huge mistake.
It would be the most
psychotic, insane thing.
JAKE WEISMAN: 99% of the
people would kill themselves,
but the 1% would truly live.
That's what I'm meant for.
BROOKE HEINICHEN: I hope
we're all in that 1%.
JAKE WEISMAN: This
is a very crazy talk.
BROOKE HEINICHEN: We're
going to take questions
from you guys in a
couple of minutes,
so start thinking about those.
I did pull another quote from
one of the episodes, which
is that "We all want
to kill ourselves,
but you can't, because the
internet cares about you."
Do you think that's true?
I mean, you're talking to
a lot of the internet here.
MATT INGEBRETSON: Oh,
yeah, that's right.
JAKE WEISMAN: The internet.
PAT BISHOP: Well, I
think it's like that's
said to a character who
his job is tweeting.
So I think people
care about you.
There are other people.
And I think, sometimes,
like even the interactions
we have can be just
through the internet,
or something that
feels like superficial.
But I feel like even
that is like positive,
or you can get something out of
that, or a reason to like live
is to find people
to connect with,
either in real
life in a real way,
or on the internet
in a fake way.
MATT INGEBRETSON:
Yeah, the internet
is just like a hyperbolic
version of what's going on.
You can live or die
by it in a crazy way.
It can turn on you, but
then make you feel good.
It's very like a
wild relationship
we have with the internet.
And the internet
cares about you.
The other thing,
too, that comes in
that episode is the internet
cares about you right now,
but tomorrow, it doesn't
care about you at all
and has forgotten
you existed, and it's
back to talking about crumb.
JAKE WEISMAN: Guys, I just
want to say something.
The show is funny.
So I know that it's very dark.
MATT INGEBRETSON: It's fun.
JAKE WEISMAN: It's
cloaked in darkness,
but there's a lot of jokes.
Please watch it.
MATT INGEBRETSON: I
don't know if we're
good salesmen for the show yet.
But we're working on that.
Whatever we need to say to get
you to watch it, we'll say it.
JAKE WEISMAN: If we were
selling clinical depression,
we would sell out.
We're the Costco knives
salesmen of depression.
BROOKE HEINICHEN: Do you
think that as corporations, I
feel like, are shifting
generally towards like very
employee-friendly
work environments--
like we have nap rooms here
at Google or free food--
and you see a lot of companies
starting to adopt that.
It's almost like a
recruitment perk.
Do you think that sort
of that the vision
of like a corporation as sort
of a jail for people's freedom
is going to change at all?
Or is it just a
nicer box to be in?
PAT BISHOP: That
seems like an excuse
to not let people go home.
If you can't afford
housing in San Francisco,
you can just stay at
work all the time.
MATT INGEBRETSON: I think,
too, that a lot of the show
comes about like the--
it's not the setting you're
in so much, but the people
around you or the
structure of it,
where you have
somebody above you,
a boss, who essentially owns
your life while you're work.
And hopefully, they're nice to
you and they're a good person.
But if they're
not, they're going
to slowly degrade your
sense of well-being
over a period of time.
JAKE WEISMAN:
Yeah, I was talking
to Aparna, Aparna Nancherla, who
is a genius and is on the show.
And she was-- she
talks about companies
doing all these wellness
things as viruses
that are getting smarter.
So really, they're just trying
to destroy you with a bigger
smile on your face.
And I don't know.
I make comedy for a living.
I really shouldn't be talking
about any of this stuff.
BROOKE HEINICHEN:
No, that's good.
I mean--
MATT INGEBRETSON: That
means that I love bean bags,
and I would love to
sit one every day.
JAKE WEISMAN: Yeah,
I mean, you guys
seem to have a good situation.
MATT INGEBRETSON: We're going
to steal some bean bags--
JAKE WEISMAN: You're
smiling a lot.
MATT INGEBRETSON:
--on the way out.
JAKE WEISMAN: I think
they're like pumping Prozac
through the vents or something.
BROOKE HEINICHEN: Heck, yeah.
Awesome.
Well, I do want to make sure
we get time for some audience
questions.
Does anyone have--
MATT INGEBRETSON:
If you don't, we're
happy to just keep talking.
Yeah.
BROOKE HEINICHEN: Do we want
to do a hand-held mic before,
because I know this-
JAKE WEISMAN: Oh, that's fun.
You guys seem like
very nice people.
MATT INGEBRETSON: By the
way, thanks for having us.
We--
JAKE WEISMAN: I've always
wanted to go to Google.
My brother-in-law works here.
I'm not going to say who he is.
BROOKE HEINICHEN:
They've got to leave here
and go back to their desks,
go back to their managers.
Try to be productive now.
AUDIENCE: Is it on?
OK.
What would you guys
change about your show
if you had like 10
times the budget?
JAKE WEISMAN: I think I would--
MATT INGEBRETSON: Well,
it would have been--
it was so hard to make
the show look like it did,
because we barely had
a budget for this show,
compared to like--
we wanted it to feel
like-- we wanted
it to feel and look
expensive, and we did not
have the money to do that.
JAKE WEISMAN: I think we
would burn stuff down.
MATT INGEBRETSON: Yeah.
JAKE WEISMAN: I mean, I
have a boyish need for fire.
So yeah, I would blow up
a building or something.
But that's about it.
I think, actually, though,
the restriction of a budget
is good.
It makes you be a
little more creative.
I don't know.
But Pat is the one
who really has to say.
PAT BISHOP: We would
have had more protesters
in that episode.
We tried to make
it look like a lot.
MATT INGEBRETSON: The practical
things that we couldn't do
are like more locations, more
extras, and more shoot days.
So that even more shots could
have been cool as fuck looking.
AUDIENCE: I have
a few questions.
I'll just ask one.
Where did the creation
and development--
how did that line up
with the 2016 election?
And do you think that the
fact that our culture,
like the greed
and everything, is
more bald-faced in the
culture makes your jokes
land more or less?
MATT INGEBRETSON: We want--
oh, go ahead.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: And let
me think if I have
another question about that.
Yeah, I'm just curious.
Like for me, I saw the
first two episodes.
I haven't seen the third.
And the fourth one, this
was the darkest for me,
by far, because of
the co-optation.
When I heard the folk
music on the sound,
that was heartbreaking.
You guys broke my fucking heart.
JAKE WEISMAN: We're trying
to break your heart.
AUDIENCE: Anyway, that's
my first question.
MATT INGEBRETSON: Well,
there are a few things.
One is that episode
was written way
before the-- is it Kylie
Jenner or Kendall Jenner?
AUDIENCE: Kylie.
MATT INGEBRETSON:
Do you remember
that Pepsi thing she did?
She did this thing where she
did like a Pepsi commercial
where she was like Pepsi was
like being with the protesters.
JAKE WEISMAN: Pepsi solved
the race wars, right?
Isn't that what it was?
MATT INGEBRETSON: It was one
of the most insane things.
And this was written
well in advance of that.
We did-- we wrote the
whole show and shot--
when did the election happen?
During the shooting?
JAKE WEISMAN: In November.
MATT INGEBRETSON:
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, yeah, 2016.
Oh, yeah, that's right.
JAKE WEISMAN: That's
when elections happen.
MATT INGEBRETSON: Oh, my God.
It's all such a crazy blur.
PAT BISHOP: It's a
repressed traumatic event.
MATT INGEBRETSON: I just
don't want to think about it.
JAKE WEISMAN: I think that we--
so obviously, Trump
is a nightmare.
There's no question about that.
And what's going on right now
is bringing that to the surface
maybe a little more
than if Hillary had won.
But I do--
MATT INGEBRETSON: A lot more.
JAKE WEISMAN: But
I don't think it
would have been any more true.
I think we were writing--
I mean, obviously, the
fact that Trump won shows
that neither
candidate was really
making America very happy.
So I do think we were
writing to whoever won.
We didn't know who-- we
thought that Hillary would win.
So we were shocked.
But I think if we wrote stuff,
it would still ring true today.
And that was our point.
Our point is not to make any
specific political points.
It's supposed to just
be about society.
We're coming at it from more
of a libertarian perspective,
I think, comedy-wise,
and just talking
about society and corporations
and their hold on society
as a whole.
MATT INGEBRETSON:
Well, yeah, I think--
yeah, exactly.
I think that regardless
of who had gotten elected,
it still would have been
about how corporations
are dominating our lives.
That was kind of
what we were trying
to get at versus
trying to comment on
like the political
space that we're in.
Although, by talking
about corporations,
you're doing that to some
extent, no matter what.
AUDIENCE: I guess my question,
and maybe you did answer it
a bit, but do you
think the jokes land
better or worse, given that
everything, all of this
is like--
MATT INGEBRETSON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It was
very hidden before,
but it's really not hidden now.
MATT INGEBRETSON: Yeah.
JAKE WEISMAN: I mean, maybe
it helps a little bit.
It's hard to say.
I mean, we weren't--
yeah, I think Trump,
just being a psychopath,
and obviously, like
corporations getting tax breaks,
like that's only going
to help us, because it's
more distrust of corporations.
But I think it's sad that
it would be more now.
People should have been
more aware, no matter what.
MATT INGEBRETSON:
Yeah, it's kind
of like I think if Hillary got
elected, this would have been
more subversive, and
kind of like a little
to the side of what
felt like was happening,
whereas now it feels like
we're all an open wound,
and so it's like watching.
Everything's burning
around us and the show
is also commenting on how
everything's burning around.
So I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Can you
tell us something
about the whole
process of pitching
the show to Comedy Central?
How did they react
to this pitch?
PAT BISHOP: Well, they--
yeah, we pitched them--
we pitched it initially as a
sketch show, essentially kind
of like "Portlandia," but
it's inside a corporation.
And they wanted
it more narrative
and kind of based
around Matt and Jake
as kind of central
characters for the audience
to like hang onto.
And I think they were
very open to-- we
were very clear about the kind
of dark tone and direction
of it from the
start, and I think
they were supportive of
that, and wanted something
that was different
from "Workaholics,"
which was the other office
place comedy show they had on.
So I think they were ready
to take a chance on something
and really responded to our kind
of like ideas visually for it.
And then we had a kind of long
development process as it goes,
but we kind of figured out
what the show should be
and how to build a world
that could allow us to hit
a lot of different topics.
And was broad enough
in its concept
to let us kind of talk
about whatever we wanted to.
JAKE WEISMAN: And
also, one reason
why we were allowed
to do the dark tone
is we made YouTube videos
and sketches for years.
And they're pretty dark.
So I mean, we think
they're silly,
but we have a general
dark tone, or what
is called the dark tone.
And we showed that for
many years on YouTube.
And so that allowed
us to be like,
we can pull this
kind of thing off.
MATT INGEBRETSON: Yeah,
what we found typically
is that development executives
who work at networks
are desperate for someone to
come in and know what they're
talking about or have like a
very specific idea, that they
spend most of their
time just like miserable
hoping that somebody comes
in with the right idea.
And so if you like
have the right idea,
it was pretty smooth
getting through it.
Although, it was a lot of work.
And it's been three years
since we had pitched it,
which is crazy to think about.
AUDIENCE: In this
last episode, you
have the CEO talking about
how the protesters are buying
the products made of oil.
And in your own show, which is
kind of like a protest against
corporations, you have
your plug for Chili's.
Is there any true
way-- or in your mind,
what would be a
true way to stage
a protest of corporations?
Is there a way to do that?
MATT INGEBRETSON: Well,
I think that I think so.
I mean, I think it essentially
is what people have been doing,
which is like the
best you can do
is try to get new
messaging out there,
and I think be aware that you
can be co-opted very easily,
or like kind of enveloped in the
capitalist system very quickly.
But I mean, we talked
about the Wall Street--
what was the Wall
Street protest called?
PAT BISHOP: Occupy.
MATT INGEBRETSON: Occupy
Wall Street as like--
that it's sort of
thought of as--
my memory is just failing me.
But it's sort of,
I think, talked
about kind of as a
failure in a lot of ways,
but we do talk about the 1%.
There's a lot of
stuff that has become
a part of the popular
like mainstream
conversation that has
resulted from that.
So I don't think the
messaging in this episode was
a little bit like it's all
futile or you will be co-opted,
but I think our actual view
is not quite that cynical.
Or I don't know.
PAT BISHOP: Yeah, it is true.
But the media is like what you
need to get your message out
there.
And the media has its
own sort of agenda,
or its own kind of
sources of funding.
So yeah, it is hard to like--
I do think there is a sort of
hesitancy to like give light
to people who are really
saying there's something
wrong with the whole system,
because so many people are
benefiting from it.
I don't know what
the solution is.
JAKE WEISMAN: I honestly
like-- and this is maybe
coming from an extremely
ridiculously privileged point
of view, but on
a personal level,
just try to do what you
want to do with your life.
Like you know what I mean?
Like what can you
really do except
follow your dreams, if you're
able to follow your dreams?
We do comedy.
It's a joke.
It's a lot of hard work.
And we work for a
corporation right now.
But it's still really fun.
And in some way, it's
a protest personally.
It's like, well, I'm
doing what I want to do.
I'm doing the best I can.
I don't know if
there's another answer.
PAT BISHOP: I do
think the internet
and just people's ability to
get videos and communication out
there has like lead to a
lot of protests and kind
of issues that weren't
coming up before coming up.
So I do think there's
positive things.
And it can be kind of chaotic,
or the kind of mob mentality
of the internet, but it is--
I think there's
more of an outlet
now than there
used to be to shine
a light on something that
people don't want to be seen.
AUDIENCE: So as comedians, what
is your actual work schedule
like?
When do you write?
How do you write?
How much time do
you spend writing?
Do you spend a lot of time doing
work not related to the show
and advancing your
comedian careers?
JAKE WEISMAN: This is
going to sound crazy.
But what we do is we just
show up on set and riff.
We work really hard.
We work really, really hard.
If you're making--
are you talking
about comedians making this show
or just comedians in general?
AUDIENCE: Oh, just
yourselves in general,
like your own kind of--
MATT INGEBRETSON: Yeah,
I feel like it's not
cool to admit how hard you
work, but we worked really hard
on this show.
JAKE WEISMAN: We work-- yeah,
we were writing like seven days
a week for many months.
And there's always
rewriting to do.
There's always
punching up to do.
And then when we're
shooting the show, I mean,
that's really hard.
That's a lot of hours per
day, every single day.
And you have to go
home, memorize lines.
Sometimes be punching up
scripts for the next day.
Again, it took us three
years to get this show
on air, and probably
like 3 and 1/2 years
from the conception of it.
So I would say in order
to make a TV show,
if you want to be good,
it's your whole life.
You're thinking about
it all the time.
It's like your child.
MATT INGEBRETSON:
Yeah, we wrote.
JAKE WEISMAN: You just
think about it constantly.
MATT INGEBRETSON:
Yeah, we wrote--
when we were writing it,
which we wrote for 12 weeks,
we wrote from like, I guess
like 10:00 to 5:00 or 6:00,
but then the three of us would
always either meet up afterward
or go home individually
and continue doing work.
So also, this is not
us complaining at all.
Just it's like we're more
than happy to do this work.
I feel like sometimes
I'm like bitching
about writing comedy
for a living, which
is like an insane job.
But there was a lot of work.
JAKE WEISMAN: It's just--
it's like as much work
as anything that's
hard to do takes.
It's seven days a week, and
it takes everything you have
and all of your intelligence.
PAT BISHOP: And then
every now and then, you
have to wait like four
months for the network
to tell you whether or not
they're going to make the show.
And you have nothing
to do except worry.
MATT INGEBRETSON: Yeah, after
we turned in the finished pilot
that we had shot, they
waited like three months
to tell us whether or not
it was going to series.
And I went on a
lot of long walks.
I got into the band Fleet Foxes.
I unexpectedly found myself
listening to Fleet Foxes a lot
in that period.
JAKE WEISMAN: If you're in--
but also, just in comedy, if
you do stand-up or you act
or whatever, like the
second you finish something,
you always feel
like you're behind.
So then we had to take time
off from performing, because we
do stand-up as well, to
then get back to stand-up
and doing that every
single night and writing.
There's always--
because it's kind
of an entrepreneurial
thing, and because comedy
is a thing that kind of doesn't
need to exist in the world,
you have to work
so much extra hard
in order to make yourself
be commercially viable.
So you're working almost every
day of the year, if you really
want to make it work, I think.
BROOKE HEINICHEN: Well,
thank you guys so much.
Hopefully, we can
see in the future
an episode of "Corporate"
based around Google,
or some sort of tech influence.
I'm excited to see how
that comes through.
Yeah, so you guys
should check out
"Corporate," Wednesdays,
10:00 PM on Comedy Central,
or online.
ComedyCentral.com, or on the
app, you can watch it there.
And let's thank these
guys for coming by today.
MATT INGEBRETSON: Thank
you guys very much.
[APPLAUSE]